Ron darling back on the show how are you
Ron hi rich
you bet so the Yankees and feast or
famine mode where they're striking out
way too much they they finally connected
last night what do you think about their
chances to even the series today Ron
well I think you know what they have I
think they have a little bit of an
advantage
McCullers jr. of course is a fantastic
young pitcher but it didn't pitch a lot
this year I don't know how he's going to
go into the game whereas funny play at
his best can really get the ball to the
the talent that they have for that
Yankee club at the end of the bullpen so
yeah chances are good today so you know
this fight was great young talent and
that's a that would even things up at
two games apiece should something like
that happen and if not then they can go
the Astor's for the kill shot with with
Keuchel on the mound and then before we
move to the NLCS that Verlander
performance in Game two was such a
throwback I mean how many times Ron have
you seen lately guy who's pitching well
seventh inning well he's got 90 pitches
let's turn it over the specialist in the
pen I loved what AJ Hinch did with
Verlander on Saturday you know it's one
of those things that we don't get to see
that much all the guy throws 120 425
pitches um you know Justin has spanned
enough time that he can not only do that
but also give way to the bull kind I
just think it's I don't know I know in
this day and age where we're asking how
can we make the games quicker the best
way to do that seven I go nine innings
and it was fun to see JB do that yeah it
was and then you know Ron it's
interesting I mentioned this yesterday I
would love to get your take on that in
the same day that we saw a throwback a
20th century type pitching performance
Jack Morris type pitching performance
back in the day Dwight Gooden right I
mean guys just go deep into games and
let's just stick with that stuff just
when we're all enjoying that the
convergence of player safety and instant
replay comes together later on that
night in Chavez Ravine where the Dodgers
get an insurance run on a replay
reversal based on a rule that was put
into place to keep catchers health
what's your take on that run yeah you
know you know my take is I was pretty
obvious probably so if you watch the
game my take is you know I think it's a
bad rule but it's always been a bad rule
I have no problem with trying to protect
anyone that's on the field I think if
someone were to go out of their way to
injure or capture that would have been a
better rule and make sure they don't pay
they don't play for the rest of the year
that would have been a rule they could
use I just think that you know the Kyle
schwarber will never make a better
defensive play than he did on that ball
with the one hop throw and of course
Contreras with a great athletic player
try to block the plate all that stuff I
think is great for the game not bad for
the game and I think the players know
the rule would be if you went out of
your way to injure a catcher you're
going to be thrown out of the game for
that year.i I think you'd very rarely
see people going through the ket room
yeah and it's interesting that seeing
baseball fans go through what NFL fans
have gone through for quite some time
and it still are with instant replay
with a Lions win being reversed at the
last second to make it a Falcons win on
the half yard line after it was called a
touchdown something that's been a
touchdown forever now no longer is when
it's parsed out the same thing with Jose
Lobaton getting thrown out at first base
in that big game 5 in Washington Ron I
mean do you think that there's gonna be
some sort of backlash to instant replay
in the offseason in the halls of
baseball Ron you know I think I think
there's gonna be some talk about it
think about it this way rich um can you
imagine if that was the last play of the
seventh game of a World Series and that
had to be reversed the call to play
plate can you imagine Jacoby Ellsbury or
Tommy la Stella the other night with
catcher's interference can you imagine
that being the last play of the World
Series with the bases loaded two outs
those are things that they're really
gonna have to look at and and work
backwards work backwards from okay what
would be the worst-case scenario for us
in a Game seven of the World Series and
then if you work backwards from there
then he can eliminate some of this stuff
Ron darling joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about Darvish
tonight what do you expect out of him in
in Wrigley this evening yeah yeah I
think what you're gonna get from the
Dodger starting pitching is is that
you're going to get five innings maybe
six and they're gonna discover that
talent of bullpen um you can see Dave
Roberts does not want his starting
pitchers to face the lineup the third
time through he wants to go straight to
that bullpen so I mean garbage could
have the same kind of game that he'll
had or it's five innings one run eight
strikeouts amazing game and get taken
out that is going to be the game plan I
think for the Dodgers and it's just the
opposite I think for the Cubs I don't
think they are as deep in the bullpen so
don't be surprised if you see Kyle
Hendricks out there for seven plus
innings well you did it in Washington
and Game one they need the same kind of
effort tonight yeah I mean the the Cubs
have yet to getting hit against the
Dodgers bullpen they're all 424 going
into Game three tonight and then
obviously way Davis is rested did you
think of Joe Joe Maddon should have put
him in against Turner and that night -
no I did that's a great question I think
the only only thing I would have changed
is I can understand Wade Davis is not
kenley jansen he's not as young he's not
a guy that can pitch six or seven outs
even though he did in the Washington
series but that was a game five I don't
even know if he's fully recovered from
that but maybe Rondon would have been a
better choice than Lackey only because
Jon never pitched on successive days in
his career and he's been around forever
and you know I think the bounce-back was
not great so maybe Rondon would have
been a better choice but I can see you
know Joseph only gonna use Davis funny
has an opportunity to win the game and
what makes a Dodgers so good I mean
you've seen them so often now Seger's
not even playing and they're up halfway
through to knock off the defending
champs right now Ron I think it's their
depth which you've seen of all summer
long but you have the ability and they
do anything but you have ability to
bring a Granderson or an ugly off the
bench Peterson to play defense late it's
that they just are so deep and I think
that just that the Indians did last year
to get to a 3-1 lead all Cubs came back
that bullpen
seems like the same formula that Terry
I only used last year and you know I'd
be hard pressed to seeing them not being
in the World Series because of that
talented Boca and and have you ever seen
someone bat flip on a double before run
I I'm seeing more and more people bat
flip I think you know it's really
interesting it's almost impossible to
try to be an analyst with yasiel Puig
because he does so many things that just
irritates you and make you upset that if
you address each and every one that
would be the entire broadcast so you
know if you were player my day you could
take care of him in a different way are
you saying your verbiage is going high
and tight Ranas oh you're saying I've
got verbiage that's all I have left
it's all you know just to wrap this up
his we had Ned Colletti in studio last
week to mean the fact that Puig was
professionally rehabilitated yeah is
remarkable when they sent him down to
Oklahoma City last summer and Roberts's
first met year's manager I thought it
was over for him and the fact that he is
not only back but back in a way that he
is a significant contributor this team
is just remember another instance of
something like that can you run no I and
I was with you I thought that at some
point because of his inability to
concentrate the pitch to pitch that he
literally was going to play himself off
the game and there's nothing worse than
great talent wasted and I'm happy for
the Dodgers and I'm happy for him
because he's too good of an athlete not
to do the kind of things that he's doing
now and you know what
you know ancillary things that doesn't
irritate him shouldn't overshadow that
tremendous athlete a tremendous player
now and then he's put in all the work
hard work to get back yes he's got
tongues wagging there's no question
about that
you take care of Ron okay I look forward
to your call tonight always authority or
calls into this show that's Ron darling
of
Turner the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
don't have any memory on your phone
let's start to delete some of those
slo-mo videos you have and you know
which ones I'm talking about